955 1874 électeurs inscrits dans les
yvelines et seulement 33 61 % de
participation avec un pourcentage aussi
faible impossible d'envisager un
candidat l'emporté dès le premier tour
obtenir la majorité et les suffrages de
25% des inscrits étant deux conditions
obligatoires pour s'affranchir d'un
second tour
pas de nouveau grand chelem pour
l'instant donc pour le parti majoritaire
sortant bien qu'il soit en tête ça n'est
pas gagné ça n'est pas parce qu'on a
fait c'est une des difficultés c'est pas
parce qu'on a eu la majorité absolue au
premier tour que on est sûr d'être élu
au deuxième tour si effectivement ce ne
sont pas les mêmes qui vont voter
il ya toujours un risque de toute façon
le principe en démocratie c'est qu'on
n'a jamais gagné avant que le dernier
bulletin soit enregistrée aux
comptes-rendus m un second tour aura
bien lieu le 27 juin dans les 21 cantons
des yvelines même si certains binômes
ont dépassé les 50% dans leur canton
comme à maurepas saint germain en laye
ou encore poissy et saint cyr l'école
nous réalisons 12 points supplémentaires
par rapport à 2015 2015 c'est la
dernière élection départementale
aujourd'hui nous sommes à près de 68 et
quelques poussières des suffrages qui se
sont portés sur suse et john hayes et
votre serviteur
pour autant tout n'est pas gagné
pourquoi parce que la participation n'a
pas été suffisante
l'abstention est un fléau et nous a
pénalisés puisque s'il y avait assez de
votants on serait passé des premiers
tours puisqu'on a fait 52 % sur le
canton
faute de votants nous allons faire un
deuxième un second tour et essayer de
mobiliser mais vraiment d'hésitation
extraordinaire extraordinaire sur saint
cyr sur bercy et surtout l'ensemble du
canton on est on est en tête partout on
va se préparer et puis on va
vouloir réunir tout le monde autour de
projets de notre projet pour une
alternative dans ce département pour
arrêter avec une politique trop
droitière qui cassent l'aide sociale et
qui détruit notre environnement l'aller
les élus actuels n'ont pas conscience de
l'urgence climatique et on peut encore
faire quelque chose le centre droit
derrière l'étiquette ensemble pour les
yvelines en tête dans 20 des 21 cantons
celui de trappes voyant la gauche en
avance de quelques 200 voix à noter que
quelques binôme du rassemblement
national se maintiennent au second tour
mais avec des résultats bien loin de
ceux attendus
le parti lepéniste espère est arrivé en
tête à bonnières sur seine